RETO MEIER: All right.
Hello, everyone.
And welcome to the Android
Studio Fireside Chat.
My name is Reto Meier.
I am a Developer Advocate
working on Android and Android
Studio.
And these fine people are
many of the folks involved
in bringing us
Android Studio 2.0.
They need no introduction.
So I'm going to make them
do their own introductions.
If each of you could go down
and introduce yourselves,
that would be fantastic.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON: Sure.
Hi, I'm Stephanie
Cuthbertson, the Group Product
Manager for Android Studio.
KATHRYN SHIH: Hi,
I'm Katherine Shih.
I'm the Product Manager for
C++ and Gaming Support as well
as Performance Tools.
JEROME DOCHEZ: Hi,
I'm Jerome Dochez.
I'm the Android Gradle
Plugin Tech Lead.
MICHAL BENDOWSKI: My
name is Michal Bendowski.
I'm an engineer on the
Gradle Plugin team.
ALEX RUIZ: Hello, my
name is Alex Ruiz.
I'm the tech lead for Project
Support, which is integration
of build system and IDs.
STEPHAN LINZNER: Stephan
Linzner, I'm a DPE,
and I work on the Android
Testing Support Library.
JAMAL EASON: Hi, I'm
Jamal Eason, a Product
Manager on Android Studio.
XAVIER DUCROHET: Hi,
I'm Xavier Ducrohet.
I'm the tech lead for
the Developer Tools.
TOR NORBYE: I'm Tor Norbye.
I'm the tech lead
for Android Studio.
ESTEBAN DE LA CANAL: Hi,
I'm Esteban De La Canal.
I'm the tech lead
for performance tools
in Android Studio.
RETO MEIER: All
right, thank you all.
So the purpose of
the fireside chat
is to give you guys
the opportunity to ask
all of these guys
anything you want
to know about Android Studio.
So I think we have one
mic set up over here.
So if you have any questions,
please line up there.
And I'll start taking some
questions once we have some.
Given that there's no
one in line yet, luckily
we have a few which we've
gathered from social media
over the last couple of days.
So I'm going to start
with one of those.
First question, nice
broad, open-ended one.
Why did the team
move to IntelliJ?
And how has that turned out?
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON: I
think Xavier should definitely
answer that one.
XAVIER DUCROHET:
It's a great ID.
You know, and that's literally.
Without that we couldn't build
a better Android-specific ID
on top of it.
And so, I hope that today's
demo, actually, showed
that we made the right choice.
And hopefully, you like it.
[APPLAUSE]
TOR NORBYE: And also, looking
around the Android team
at the time, everyone
who had a choice of ID
was using IntelliJ.
And the Android Tools team
was pushing another ID.
And so we thought, well, you
know, if the coding is so good,
maybe that's what we
should give our users.
RETO MEIER: Seems the
reasonable approach.
A question from the
audience, please.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have two questions.
One of them is from
yesterday, actually.
I wanted to just ask
about Jack and Jill,
and more specifically,
if there are going
to be any implications
for using other languages
once that starts rolling out in
a more official and stable way?
Specifically, like if
we're using Kotlin,
and Jack and Jill
becomes the default build
tool, what will happen then?
XAVIER DUCROHET:
So yeah, we don't
have much to talk about
in terms of Jack and Jill.
It's still a work in progress.
You can try it right now.
It's still
integrating in Gradle.
I think we made a little
bit of improvement
in the actual
Gradle integration.
But there isn't a
whole lot to talk about
until it's a featured parity
with the current toolchain,
javac and dx.
We may just switch it
as being the default,
but we're not there yet anyway.
So when that happens, hopefully
not too long from now,
we'll do that.
In the meantime, there
isn't much talk about.
So regarding
languages, we are aware
that, even though we
have a new toolchain,
we know that you guys
want to be able to use
different even libraries, right.
Even without talking
about languages,
if you can't reuse any
libraries, that's a problem.
So that's what Jill is for,
supporting any Java bytecode
and integrating that and
converting that into dx.
So an integration
with Kotlin could be
like using the Kotlin compiler.
And then inserting
that into Jill,
and then converting
that into dx.
So it's not impossible.
It may not be the
most efficient path.
But it's definitely possible.
AUDIENCE: Cool, thank you.
And the second question was
about the performance test
tools that were talked about
earlier today in the test
session.
I was wondering if we
instrument with those tests,
will the Cloud Test Lab run
those tests on the devices,
on physical devices, that
we specify and give us
the performance
[INAUDIBLE] dumps.
Because that would
be really awesome.
STEPHAN LINZNER: So essentially,
right now it's just rules.
But we definitely work
with the Cloud Test Lab
to get these integrated.
And I think we want to
look at the broader story
to, not only have it
in Cloud Test Lab,
but maybe also in
Android Studio.
And surface the data
better so that you
can get signals if something
changes over time, yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RETO MEIER: Thank you,
the next person, please.
AUDIENCE: Hi, when Java 8
will be officially supported
and available to all
Android developers
be a little more happy?
XAVIER DUCROHET: So you
need to go yesterday
and I ask the
Framework team first.
I know that they punted
some questions to us.
So I'm going to punt
a question to them.
You know, I mean, it's
not just a tool issue.
So you're asking just
one half of Android.
By half I mean like 10%, right.
Android is a big team.
TOR NORBYE: Well,
the Java 7 support
was done by the Framework first.
And then once that was done,
then we could, of course, do--
XAVIER DUCROHET: I mean there
isn't a whole lot of work
to do on the tool side, right.
Like IntelliJ supports Java 8.
You have JDK, you
have javac, you know.
It's all there, right.
And so it's, first,
a platform problem.
And you're asking the
wrong people, sorry.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON:
What I would say though is,
it's nice that you
asked that question.
Because I probably have taken
it seven times at lunch now/
I'm not getting a chance
to eat my dessert.
I think that,
certainly, there have
been a wide range of
people who have asked us
for Java 8 support.
It's definitely something
we're looking at.
The number one thing that we
hear when people ask for Java i
support is lambdas.
so if it's lambdas you want,
you should affirm that.
If there's other specific
language features that
are very high
priority for you, it
would be great to know
about those as well.
And I think we'd say we
appreciate the feedback.
But we don't have anything
specific to share right now.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RETO MEIER: We'll
take this opportunity.
Who would like
lambdas, specifically?
[APPLAUSE]
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON:
There we go.
RETO MEIER: So that's
something of an affirmation.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON:
Yep, that's great.
RETO MEIER: Thank you.
We'll take you as well.
AUDIENCE: So the Android
tools site is a little rough.
[LAUGHTER]
RETO MEIER: Can you rephrase?
What do you mean?
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON: Is there
anyone here from the Android
Tool site team?
We'd love to have
you come up on stage.
No, I'm kidding.
Keep talking.
AUDIENCE: I mean
it's not typically
a very useful place to visit.
The road map still mentions your
post-Android Studio 1.0 plans.
TOR NORBYE: Yeah, so it's true
that there's a couple of things
that are obsolete on there.
I think I would disagree
that it's not useful.
It's where we post
a lot of information
that we can do
directly as engineers,
as opposed to having
it sort of written up
and go through the whole
putting it into proper English.
So you know, it's
the place where
you can find the
authoritative source
on what you can do in the
build system, for example.
And there's a number of other
documents we put out there,
and then that have since been
processed by professional doc
writers into real documentation.
So it's good for that.
But it's true that the
road map, and don't we
have a document that says
what we would like help with?
And it's probably
five years old.
Yeah so, apologies for
the outdated content.
RETO MEIER: It has a
superset of information.
So it's got useful information,
but also other information.
TOR NORBYE: Yeah,
but it is helpful
when people complain
that it's out of date.
Then we do try to fix it.
The road map is tricky.
Because, I think it's a
policy, we don't generally
talk about stuff in the future.
XAVIER DUCROHET: So
there's a couple of things
that we do want to migrate
and to significantly improve
the documentation for Gradle.
We already started
publishing the DSA reference.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
that's a good example.
XAVIER DUCROHET: So we do
want to integrate better
into developer.android.com.
We do want to have a
proper user guide also
on developer.android.com.
So everything that's
been officially released
in the stable
channel, we do want
to migrate to
developer.android.com
And we're starting to have
some plan to work on that soon.
You know, tools.android.com
is a good place for us
to put information about stuff
that's not stable, right.
On developer.android.com,
we don't
want to preview things
that are not final,
things that may change
before they get released.
So we'll keep using it more as
a, hey, here's the 2.0 Canary.
You know, here's a bunch
of stuff to look at it.
That's the place where you'll
find that kind of information.
But we do want to migrate
stuff that's now being promoted
to stable, like hey, Gradle
is the official build system,
to developer.android.com.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
RETO MEIER: Please.
AUDIENCE: Hi, guys.
Are there any plans to create
a more, like an integration
for CI into Android Studio?
XAVIER DUCROHET: Which CI?
AUDIENCE: OK, I assume everybody
is using Jenkins, probably,
or a lot of people.
XAVIER DUCROHET: I don't know.
Who is using Jenkins?
TOR NORBYE: Oh. [INAUDIBLE].
XAVIER DUCROHET: OK, who
is using something else?
That's still a
good number, right.
So I mean, we do want
to improve our CI story.
I don't know that, actually,
integrating that into Studio
is the number one goal.
Maybe we should first
have a CI story.
You know, you can use
Jenkins right now.
But it's not awesome.
You have to do a lot of
manual configuration.
And we do want to
improve that first.
So once we have that, we'll
probably look at what else
we can do to make it
an end-to-end story.
TOR NORBYE: It would
be good to know what it
is you feel is missing as well.
Because I know that there are
plugins for a lot of things.
So running unit tests, Android
tests, should be pretty--
XAVIER DUCROHET: I think
he was talking specifically
about Studio
integration with CI.
TOR NORBYE: Do you want
like a build notification
when a job is done and failed?
Or what specifically
do you want in the IDE?
AUDIENCE: OK, I was
recently asked by a PM
about if Android
Studio has something
like the really nice dashboards
that Xcode has for the Xcode
bots.
XAVIER DUCROHET:
OK, so a dashboard
of running jobs, the ability
to right click and say
kill this job, give
my job more priority.
OK, got it.
[LAUGHTER]
RETO MEIER: Request noted.
Please, if other people have
questions, please jump up.
It's a good opportunity
to ask hard questions,
because there's not too many.
So they can take their
time answering them.
In the meantime, I do
have a few from online,
which I can pass on.
This one asks, why is
ADB throughput so poor?
USB 2 can do like
16 mbs, but ADB
seems to cap out at about
3 megabits, et cetera.
So why is ADB
throughput so poor?
XAVIER DUCROHET: Because
the product code is stupid.
[LAUGHTER]
JEROME DOCHEZ: That's
a long answer, right?
XAVIER DUCROHET:
Yeah, yeah, I mean
it sends like a little bit of
data, then it waits for an ACK,
and then sends a
little bit more data,
and then waits for an ACK.
Yeah, it's broken.
So we are fixing it.
We have a better
protocol coming.
I don't know how it
was designed that way,
but it was a poor decision.
JAMAL EASON: And
initially, we were
adding just better throughput
just on the ADB side,
but also on the devices.
We talked about that
in the emulator talk.
And you know, it's
just basically looking
at increasing the throughput
on both of the devices,
which just makes it faster.
RETO MEIER: Great,
another question here,
talking about the emulator.
Excited to try it,
but still disappointed
by how long it has taken to
just boot up in the past.
So has the boot speed
for the emulator
improved in the new version?
JAMAL EASON: Yes, so we didn't
really talk about it as much.
But we mentioned about
faster CPU speed.
So the boot was really about
loading files onto the emulator
and starting it up.
So with the impact of dual-core
support, multi-core support,
we actually can go faster.
And you'll see that
later on when we actually
release it for release.
RETO MEIER: Fantastic.
A question from the audience.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, this also
came up yesterday, I guess.
But I was wondering why
some of the artifacts
are published in the report
like JCentral and Maven Central,
while others are only delivered
to the support development, SDK
Management.
So why is it supported
and not [INAUDIBLE]?
XAVIER DUCROHET: So you have
to click through a license
to get those.
And JCentral and Maven Central
do not allow that workflow.
That's it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
RETO MEIER: Easy answer.
Another question from online.
Can I use Instant Run to improve
turnaround times on pipelines
outside of Android Studio?
So they want to take advantage
of all the cool things you've
done, but do it
outside of your tool.
Is such a thing possible?
TOR NORBYE: Why would
they want to do that?
RETO MEIER: Next question.
I couldn't imagine.
TOR NORBYE: Currently it's
built inside of Android Studio.
So the connection to the
app is maintained by Studio.
It's not done from
the Gradle plugin.
So there is no way to.
XAVIER DUCROHET: And you
know, Gradle doesn't really
talk continuously to
devices, but Studio does.
Studio monitors file changes,
which Gradle doesn't do.
So there's a lot
of things that we
can do where, if
the integration was
done, if it was
just done in Gradle,
it would not be as good.
TOR NORBYE: Plus, even
the pushing to the device
is not done through
Gradle today.
It's done in Studio.
And Studio maintains a cache
of check sums and things
like that to make
sure that it doesn't
have to push the same
app over and over again.
We'd have to put a lot
of stuff in Gradle.
We'd have to put Studio in
Gradle, really, to do this.
RETO MEIER: Great,
that's a good answer.
A couple of related questions,
where is Studio support for C++
going?
And are there any
new features related
to the NDK in
Android Studio 2.0?
KATHRYN SHIH: So I don't
think 2.0, per se, has new NDK
features, except for
the GPU profiler.
There have been features
released shortly before 2.0,
mostly the stuff
I covered today,
so the experimental
Gradle support.
I guess that's either before
or after 2.0, depending
on whether you count the
day it was experimental
or the day it stops
being experimental.
Then similarly, the
debugger support
is either right
before or right after,
depending on your counting.
As far as the more broadly where
it's going, in the short term,
I think, I probably could not
say with a straight face that
there are no rough edges
in the C++ experience.
There's a number of
rough edges, as anyone
who's tried it will testify.
And so, for the
short to medium term,
we're really just focused on
sanding those down and making
it so the C++ experience is
as smooth and easy as the Java
experience can be.
I think long-term
plans will come
after we get to that point.
RENO MEIER: That
makes a lot of sense.
Will Android Studio ever
support mipmap suggestions
in XML layout editing?
TOR NORBYE: Say
it one more time.
RETO MEIER: Will Android Studio
ever support mipmap suggestions
in XML layout editing?
TOR NORBYE: Yeah,
we should do that.
RETO MEIER: Great.
Yeah, that's easy.
Anyone else has
feature requests,
now is probably a good time.
TOR NORBYE: The word
was ever, right?
There was no specific timeline.
RETO MEIER: Ever.
TOR NORBYE: It will.
RETO MEIER: Yeah.
OK, great.
You've heard it here first.
OK, another question, again,
with a non-defined timeline.
I know you announced
the Eclipse deprecation.
When will it officially
be deprecated?
JAMAL EASON: Well, just
to clarify, so we actually
deprecated it, Eclipse.
Which means you
should not use it.
RETO MEIER: So some time
in the past is the answer.
JAMAL EASON: What's that?
RETO MEIER: Sometime in
the past is the answer.
JAMAL EASON: In the past, right.
But yeah, I mean,
really the focus
has been on Android
Studio for some time.
And if you haven't
made the conversion,
all this cool stuff is
not available on Eclipse.
So really, use Android
Studio and migrate over.
If you have issues,
please let us know.
We can help you through that.
RETO MEIER: OK, let's see.
Would a feature like
Saving Custom Templates
be introduced in any
future version of Studio?
Because that would be great.
XAVIER DUCROHET: Saving
custom templates.
TOR NORBYE: Well, we
support it now, kind of.
RETO MEIER: It's
very convincing.
TOR NORBYE: Yeah, the only
way you can do it right now
is you put your custom
templates in the SDK folder
under Extras Templates.
The only people I
know who do this
are typically book
authors, right.
Because then they
could very easily
do a repeatable thing
for each chapter.
I don't know.
Is that a feature lot of
people are excited about?
OK, well, we have
one or two votes.
Yeah, given all the other
things we are trying to do,
I don't know if it's
top of our list.
But we could always consider it.
MICHAL BENDOWSKI: I [INAUDIBLE]
imagine, for example
like, [INAUDIBLE] to
provide custom templates,
specifically for this library.
And other library
authors might be
interested in doing
something like this.
RETO MEIER: A question
from the audience, please.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the
AOSP Bug Tracker, there
have been a few
passes, it seems,
of bugs that are still active
being marked as obsolete.
How should the community
interpret that.
What is the meaning of the
obsolete closing status?
XAVIER DUCROHET: Are you talking
about some recent handful
of bugs, or a large number
of bugs that were suddenly
marked as obsolete?
AUDIENCE: Well, I think I've
seen multiple passes of it.
But there was one very
large bulk closing.
You know, there have been
numerous comments of saying,
no I still experience this.
A couple of these were things
that I was still seeing.
So there was this bulk closing.
So I guess what was the--
XAVIER DUCROHET: So
some of the bulk closing
that happened were
just some people
on the platform realizing
that, hey, no one is
looking at those bugs.
There's probably some
people who are still
hoping that we'll fix them.
But since no one
is looking at them,
let's actually tell people
that we're not looking at them,
rather than just
give false hope.
You know, that's not
the main bug tracker
for the Android team.
We, on the Tools
team, we do use it.
This is our main tracker.
But for the platform team
we have an internal tracker.
And you know, Android
engineers on the platform
may not look at it as
often as maybe they should.
Some do.
And there's been some
good improvement,
I think, recently from people
looking at it more closely.
But if you have some bugs
that are dating from 2008,
when you released Android 1.0.
It's like, realistically,
we're not going to fix them.
We might as well
just close them.
TOR NORBYE: So most of the
obsolete bugs I've closed
have been, their filed
against Studio 0.4, 0.5, 0.8.
And the point is,
that to us that
is as ancient as Android 1.0
would be for the Android team,
right.
So we have someone reporting
a stack trace where nothing
really is current anymore.
And we could spend a lot
of time investigating that.
But given the high
volume of reports we get,
it's probably better to
close those as obsolete.
So that people
don't put duplicates
for a very similar symptom, but
pointing to old information.
XAVIER DUCROHET: So I don't
think we've done bulk closing.
But we have closed all
the ones like that.
Yeah, I mean, if there's
a bug that you think
is still there and really
should be fixed, just reopen it,
if it's on a newer
version of Android, right.
If it's still on
Marshmallow, just reopen it.
JAMAL EASON: I would
add, if you file bugs,
make sure you have clear
repro steps and screen shots.
Because some of the bugs
we have are just like,
hey, it doesn't work.
And you can't really
work with those things.
So be clear with all the
instructions on the bug
templates, and we can
respond back to you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RETO MEIER: Please.
AUDIENCE: On the
unit testing site,
so now unit testing
works really good.
So everything that comes
basically from Android
is the place for
unit testing, right.
This Android draft is generated.
But a lot of things come from
the support libraries or get
moved to the support libraries.
So this is like real cool
that it's not marked out.
Any solution there, or is
someone working on those?
The unit testing of things that
come out of support library
gets easier?
MICHAL BENDOWSKI: So what
exactly is the question?
You would like us to
provide what exactly?
AUDIENCE: When something
like a [INAUDIBLE]
for the support libraries.
MICHAL BENDOWSKI: You
mean to make this support
libraries [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: So if
you use something,
a little support library, like
extended view or something,
you cannot unit test it anymore
because there's a lot of code
running there suddenly.
Is there a way to mock this.
But everything that comes out
of Android itself, it's a view,
there is no code running when
the unit tests are running.
MICHAL BENDOWSKI:
We're not actively
working on it at the moment.
But it's on our road map.
We actually discussed
it, how we could actually
extend our support
to support libraries
and to GMS core and whatnot.
We will be looking at
it next year, hopefully.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
RETO MEIER: I've got a slightly
open-ended question here
from online.
It says the performance tools
are getting better rapidly
but need some more work.
What's the plan for
performance tools?
ESTEBAN DE LA CANAL: I
can probably answer that.
So if you saw the
talk before, we
are investing heavily on the
line performance analysis.
So the monitors
that you are seeing
is where we're investing.
So we're going to invest
in memory, CPU, battery.
A lot of you asked
me about when are you
going to do something
about batteries?
We are going to
be doing something
about battery performance.
And the direction is, we want
to give you as much information
as we can without you having
to actually go and profile
your app.
And then if you
really find a problem
that you don't
know how to solve,
then we will give
you the right tools
to dig deep into that problem
particularly and analyze it.
RETO MEIER: Great.
ESTEBAN DE LA CANAL:
That's the direction.
RETO MEIER: A question
from the audience.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I had a
question about the Instant Run
functionality and
how hard it would
be for a third-party language
to hook into that feature?
Would it just be about producing
a sufficiently granular
incremental build?
Or is there a very
involved pipeline
that they would
have to implement?
JEROME DOCHEZ: OK, I
guess that's for me.
So you're talking about
something like Kotlin,
for instance.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JEROME DOCHEZ: Right, so
in theory, the Instant Run
is hooking up on the
class file format already.
So as long as your tool is
producing a normal class
file, in theory we should be
able to hook up fairly easy.
However, we've never tried.
So chances are,
it's not working.
But yes, we are definitely doing
the [INAUDIBLE] instrumentation
at the class file level.
We just load the
[INAUDIBLE] class files
and we instrument those.
There's not much magic here.
We've seen these around
for quite many years.
TOR NORBYE: And there's
the new transforms
API, which is basically
allowing more plugins to work.
JEROME DOCHEZ: So I don't know
if you went to Xavier's talk
earlier today.
But there is the
Transform API, which
will help you introducing
your transformer.
But that probably won't take
care of the Kotlin compiler.
But still, there are
many ways that we'll
be able to hook up your code.
AUDIENCE: Awsome, thank you.
RETO MEIER: And
another question.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm wondering
if there are any plans
to include UI test recording.
So Xcode has some sort of
where you just click around,
it starts recording your step.
And then you can
just replay them.
Is that something that
may come in the future?
STEPHAN LINZNER: I mean,
it's certainly something
that we look at.
Because right now
I can get on stage.
I can tell you,
how your Espresso
is so awesome and so easy.
But at the end of the day
you have to write your test.
And so yeah, it's
something that makes
recording UI tests easier.
It's also something
that's interesting for us
because we can inject best
practices through code
generation.
But yeah, it's
obviously something
that will improve and
drive adoption of Espresso.
So we certainly look at
these kind of approaches.
But we are not actively
working on it right now.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RETO MEIER: Another
question from social media.
Will it be possible to
use Instant Run for apps
with multidex enabled, so
with more than 65,000 methods?
JEROME DOCHEZ: It
actually already works.
RETO MEIER: Fantastic.
JEROME DOCHEZ: So it's better if
you use the native multidexing.
It's going to make
it much faster.
But I was actually helping
somebody earlier today
who was running
into the 65k limit
when he enabled his
application with Instant Run.
And we switched to
multidex, and it worked.
Except we were surprised
about how many methods
we were adding.
But we'll work on that.
So yeah, we know it works.
RETO MEIER: Fantastic.
Another question
from the audience.
AUDIENCE: I have
a second question.
It's about, we have those
annotations, non-null
and nullable for a while
now, which will be nice.
But they only will be
shown in Android Studio as
like a warning, but it is not
part of Lint, as far as I know.
So is there any way to trigger
this by Lint so that a CI will
say, hey there is a hold up.
You're using something
that is null?
TOR NORBYE: Yeah,
the problem is that,
to support that from
Lint, we'd basically
have to duplicate functionality.
When you run it in Studio, it's
done by IntelliJ basically.
So Lint doesn't run that
stuff on the command line.
So we'd have to go to the
trouble of reimplementing
all that for Lint's own uses.
Which may not be worth it.
So the easier way to
do it is to just run
IntelliJ's own inspections
from the command
line, which you can do.
If you look at Distribution,
there is an Inspect LSH script.
So you do that plus a profile
XML File that you can make.
And you can run that from CI.
You just get an XML file.
No you don't.
You get lots of XML
files, one per inspection.
But you can do your
own little command line
processing of that.
XAVIER DUCROHET: We should a
better integration for that.
TOR NORBYE: We should.
Yeah, good point.
AUDIENCE: Thanks [INAUDIBLE].
RETO MEIER: Great, let's take
another audience question.
AUDIENCE: My
question [INAUDIBLE].
So how did you make a decision
to advise the Android Studio
version to 2.0 instead of
just one point something?
RETO MEIER: What
justifies the extra 0.4?
KATHRYN SHIH: It's interesting,
because we debated it
quite a bit internally.
Because I will say that, in
our own engineering team,
I think it's fair to say
the bar is very high.
And the team feels strongly
about not over promising.
So we debated at quite some
length about the numbering.
And ultimately, I think it would
be great if a couple of people
weighed in on this as well.
But there are a
few major features
that we felt were significant
in how they changed
the way you will develop.
Probably the most
significant of those,
as everyone in the audience that
I've talked to in the last two
days, has mentioned
is Instant Run.
Because it really does
change the way you develop.
And several of us
have it running.
Once you get used to
running with Instant
Run, the ones of us who
have had it live for quite
some time find, even
though there certainly
were some bugs in the
early implementations,
you just don't ever
want to have it off.
Because it just
completely changes.
You always end up writing
code with the emulator up,
or the device up, and
seeing how it runs.
I think the changes
in the emulator
are also very significant.
And the two in
combination are important.
Because together, you
can execute code and see
the results very quickly.
Those were two of the
most driving forces.
I would say the code
search features are also
quite significant.
And actually, probably
the other biggest one
was the integration of
IntelliJ 15, which I think,
as we mentioned, the
team did very rapidly.
It really did just come
out three weeks ago
for those of you guys
who watch IntelliJ 15.
And it has a really
wide range of features.
We didn't talk
about all those, we
didn't enumerate them
specifically in the keynote.
Although I think Tor did kind
of an amazing job of walking you
through some of the cool
things you get with IntelliJ.
But those were probably
the three biggest things
that drove us to do it, IntelliJ
15, the emulators, and Instant
Run.
Does anybody else
want to talk specific?
It wasn't a decision
that we made lightly.
Because we feel so strongly
about not over promising.
TOR NORBYE: But I think
the other thing is that we
released 1.0 about a year ago.
So it seems like going to a
major revision a year later
is fair.
Otherwise, we'd start
like 1.10, 1.11, right.
XAVIER DUCROHET: And also like
last year, we did IntelliJ 14
on the 1.2.
And it felt like, at
least to some of us,
that the switch from 1.1 to 1.2,
when we got all of IntelliJ 14.
It was like a brand new
debugger, UI, and all of that.
It was kind of like
the 1.2 didn't really
show all the things
you guys were getting.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RETO MEIER: Surprisingly
detailed answer.
Another question.
AUDIENCE: OK, hi it's me again.
Just one thing
about the CI bits.
I really care about
the dashboard thing.
But having a plugin that I could
use to configure Jenkins tasks
and hit Run for manual-built
jobs would be really nice.
So that's just like
the part before that.
And after that, I have one
other question about tests.
It would be really nice to
have performance tests where
I can set a performance
goal for, like, Method X.
And then have the test
running and then get alert
when my performance is
deteriorating for some reason.
That would be really cool.
Any ideas about that?
STEPHAN LINZNER: So if you
look at the actual code lab,
it actually uses a
time out in the test.
And so if you have a Janky test.
And it goes past this time out,
the test will actually fail.
So go downstairs and
look at the code lab.
Or do it from home.
It's already in there.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
ESTEBAN DE LA
CANAL: Another thing
to add on the
performance side, we
are planning all the
analysis I mentioned
we will do live on your app.
We are planning on also
porting that to a library
that you can use on
the CI environment.
So you could check, for
example, linked activity
running your tests.
So that's something
we are planning.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question about the future.
I know you don't
like those, but I
think I ask this for all of us.
Are we going to have an Android
Dev Summit in the future?
RETO MEIER: They've
asked the right people.
I hope so.
Have you guys enjoyed
this Dev Summit?
[APPLAUSE]
I will pass that raucous
applause on to the organizers.
We've certainly
enjoyed having it.
Have you guys enjoyed
this as a venue
to launch your
new product, yeah?
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON:
I'd love to hear, again,
other folks talk about it.
It's been incredibly
valuable for us.
Because, especially
with this audience,
with the folks who
have chosen to attend
this conference, the depth of
the questions and the feedback
that we're getting.
The technical depth and the
understanding that you have,
it's tremendously valuable
to the engineering team.
And I'm sure you guys have
noticed, the caliber of folks
that you're getting
from the engineering
teams of Android Studio, Android
Platform Android Framework.
You've seen all of these
really very foundational people
for Android Studio.
You've seen Dianne
Hackborn, a very wide range
of people who are quite
critical in the decisions that
drive Android.
And so the feedback is just
tremendously valuable for us.
I think a key question
for us, of course,
because it's a lot
of time for you is,
is this really worth your time?
So I think that's probably the
main thing we need to know.
How many people in
the audience would
attend something like this
again, if we were to do it?
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
RETO MEIER: So to most people.
Yeah, I mean, I think I can
speak for the people here,
specifically.
We would love to be
able to do this again.
So yeah, we hope so, I guess.
But none of us are going
to make that decision.
So take that for
what it's worth.
We've got no one
else behind the mic.
I do have a couple
more questions here.
Let's see, what have we got?
When do you plan to enable
Instant Run for library
projects, e.g. one
library and one demo
module in the same project?
JEROME DOCHEZ: So we will
do, the first support
will be for this
subprojects of your,
the submodule of your project.
For the libraries, so
far we don't really
have a plan do this.
Because we think that,
most of the time,
you are not changing the
libraries you're consuming.
Maybe there would be a mode.
I don't know.
We can still think about it.
I'm not convinced
it's necessary.
I'm definitely convinced
we need to do it
for the main project
and the other modules.
Just a module,
just the projects,
I don't thing for library
it's really necessary.
I think it should be the
library developer that
should have his Instant Run
when he's producing his library,
not you when you're
consuming it.
TOR NORBYE: Well,
just to be clear,
if you have a library
in your project
that is a direct
module dependency.
Even though it's a library,
that we do Instant Run.
Because, really only when
you have a third-party, Maven
Central or JCenter
artifact, that's the case
we're talking about.
I don't think you're
modifying those.
So it does work.
It's not like you
can only Instant
Run your main app, module, all
the modules in your program.
JEROME DOCHEZ: Well, actually,
today it's only the main app.
The Preview Tool
we will actually
support the other modules.
RETO MEIER: Question
from the audience.
AUDIENCE: This is just a
followup on the future Android
Dev Summit plans.
If there is another one,
can we request that it not
be Thanksgiving week?
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
JEROME DOCHEZ: Can we also
request it's in Bora Bora,
or someplace like that?
RETO MEIER: That doesn't
necessarily help everyone here.
Yes, noted.
Let's have a look.
This might be a little bit more
for the Android Framework team.
But we've got time.
I'll ask your opinion.
What are your thoughts on using
event libraries, like EventBus,
compared to local
broadcast manager?
Any opinions?
[LAUGHTER]
You have no thoughts.
TOR NORBYE: Well, I know
which ID you should edit in.
[LAUGHTER]
RETO MEIER: Good.
Oh, people to save me, please.
AUDIENCE: Nobody's
asking about Glass, what?
I actually have more of a
request than a question.
A number of times on stage, the
Framework team in particular,
has referred to Stack Overflow
and getting answers off
of Stack Overflow.
And it seems like a
lot of tech support
and a lot of interaction
with developers
has been outsourced
to Stack Overflow.
So I'm just, kind of,
requesting and asking
that Google might take a
little more responsibility.
In the early days with
the Google Groups,
members of the Android team
used to answer questions.
Ramon and Diane were
responding to developers.
We could count on their answers.
And we can count on Mark
Murphy, kind of, sort of.
And there are a lot of
good tutorial sites.
But most of the examples
and example code
are over simplified.
And when you're
actually using some
of these objects
in practice, you
need to look at questions
around threading or larger input
objects.
And so, that would be something
I hope that you can take back
to the entire Android
team about helping
us to be more effective.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON:
Actually, I
think you probably couldn't
have asked us something
that would make us happier.
There's quite an internal
discussion going on
for us about a desire
to dramatically deepen
the level of technical
content that we have.
And so, I think you can see the
level of passion the team has
by the fact that there's a
lot of people sitting up here
to connect with the Dev Summit.
Would anyone else like to--
because this is certainly
something we've talked
about quite a bit.
Anybody else want to talk
about our aspirations--
TOR NORBYE: Well, there is
the generating documentation.
But I also heard a bit of
tech support in that question,
right.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON: Yes.
TOR NORBYE: So I think it's
hard to both finish Instant Run,
and at the same time
answer lots of questions.
So that's kind of a
difficulty we have,
balancing the how much time
you spend looking through user
forums and responding
and following up,
and how much do you time
to your daytime job.
XAVIER DUCROHET: But I think
we can do a better job about,
you know like, creating
a user guide for Gradle.
OK, we want to do that.
Having the DSA reference.
But we've talked in the past
about having a lot of recipes.
And that's kind of like
what we did during our talk.
You know, it's like
here's a few things
that, if you're trying to
do that, do it that way.
And be more proactive
about showing
best practices on
a lot of use case
that we know developers
need to do anyway.
You know, it doesn't really
fit in the user guide
where you're really
teaching the workings.
But just saying, hey,
if you want to do that,
here's how you do it.
I think, if we
publish more of those
and then they get
indexed anyway,
they'd be more discoverable.
As Tor said, like at the
beginning, Android Beginner
and Android Developer
on Google Groups,
there wasn't that
many developers.
And our team or smaller too.
But there was still a pretty
big load of questions to answer.
Nowadays, it's like
I can't keep track.
There's just too many of them.
So sometimes, some developer
will point me, saying, hey,
can you answer that
question because I
can't get a good answer.
And more often than
not, it's not really
a good question anyway.
But when it is, I try to help.
But it's hard.
There are so many of them.
And I think what Joe was saying
about bug reporter is very
important for Stack Overflow.
I see a lot of questions that
are just like, not just read
the doc.
But I'm less inclined to
answer if you don't even
try to really explain to
me what the problem is.
Just saying, hey, doesn't
work just doesn't help me.
KATHRYN SHIH: Well, that's
not anybody here, right.
XAVIER DUCROHET: Well,
hopefully, hopefully.
But well, it's live stream so
everyone is watching that too.
You know it's important, right.
So if you're asking
for help online,
try to make it
easy on the person.
TOR NORBYE: But just I want
to say for Stack Overflow.
Sure there maybe
are lots of, I don't
want to say dumb
questions, but maybe they
could have tried
a little harder.
But often, when you're
trying to find something out
and you search for it, the
best hit is Stack Overflow.
You had the exact same question.
Five other people hit it.
And people have loaded up
and down the solutions.
So often for me, I find
the actual answer there.
But maybe that's
because I don't know
what I'm doing when it comes
to Android development.
And if it was a tools
question be like, no no,
that's a wrong answer.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON: Actually,
I'll say one more thing,
and then, actually,
we should probably
go on to the next question.
So you can see the depth
of technical answers
and documentation is something
we're very passionate about.
I think we talked some about
the momentum of Android Studio
recently, with things
like 103 releases
and things of that nature.
It's 2.0.
The usage is enormous,
and the growth--
I think one thing that
we would be open about
is that the growth
of Android Studio,
as explosive as it
has been, has slightly
scaled beyond our ability to
keep up with everyone who is
using it and asking questions.
And so, Reto was
actually pretty modest
when he introduced himself.
We recently inaugurated him as
the first ever Android Studio
advocate in residence.
And that was really
acknowledging
that we need to
dramatically scale up
our outreach and ability
to answer questions.
Because, as amazing as
the engineering team is,
it's just not scalable for us
to answer every single question
out of the engineering
team to keep up
with all the questions
coming out of the community.
So thank you very
much for the feedback.
And we've got to move
on to the next question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, as a segue, the
Android Wear team, for example,
I have some friends, some people
in Cambridge that I've met.
And they don't know,
in developer relations,
they might refer me to.
And so, if the developer
relations team is that divorced
from the engineering
team, then the community
might not be getting
correct answers.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON: The
developer relations team
works very closely with
the engineering team.
So that's definitely
not an issue.
AUDIENCE:That was my experience.
You know, go to Stack
Overflow, rather
than go to Developer Relations.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON:
Yeah, they definitely
work very closely together.
I would be happy to
talk more offline.
We can sync up.
I'll be in the booth
after the discussion.
AUDIENCE: Right,
it's just my request.
If it's Developer
Relations, great.
Maybe we can beef it up.
And just having
more opportunities
to get the best answers.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
As the resident developer
relations person
up here, I should
probably answer.
Steph was very kind.
Basically she said,
in a very polite way,
that I have to fix that problem.
So I will definitely be
taking that on board.
We have so many smart people.
We should have all
of the answers.
And clearly one of the
key things we can do
is develop relationships
is help make sure
that the most pressing
questions that you have
are answered by
the right people.
So helping to create that
funnel, be that interface,
is a big part of what
we're going to do.
And definitely something
we want to improve on.
So thank you for the feedback.
Another question, please.
AUDIENCE: So as
the Android build
toolchain has
gotten more complex,
more things go on
between your Java
and the class files
that come out.
You have more generated code.
Is there any tips for, you
know, this is my dot Java.
I want to see what came out
the other side, as opposed
to kind of spelunking through
the intermediates directory.
For instance, if
I want to see how
this resource ends
up getting packaged.
XAVIER DUCROHET:
So for resources,
we have, for Java, I don't think
there's much besides-- I mean,
you would have to go through
the Intermediate folder
and look at all the different
transformance, see the output,
and then see the
classes for that export.
But for the resources,
at least for merging,
which is one case where you
could have a resource that
gets replaced by another one.
Let's say you have one
in Source Main Res,
and then you have one
in Source Debug Res.
You could not realize
maybe that the one in Debug
replaced the one in Source Main.
We do have a blame,
sort of file now.
Because we need it for APT.
Where when APT runs on
the result of the merge,
we want to make
sure that we display
the errors as your
actual original file
as it is in Source Main or
Source Debug, which was not
the case before.
Before you would
see APT complain
about a file that
was an intermediary
as being a problem.
And you were like, why
is that file there?
I don't even know
where the source is.
So we could expose that
potentially in Studio.
TOR NORBYE: I think they do.
If you do Show
Documentation on a Resource,
we show the overlays,
and we strike out.
So if you have a base resource
and you have a debug overlay,
we'll show the debug value.
And then we'll show the
other one with strike through
to show that it was hidden.
XAVIER DUCROHET:
And there you go.
It's all right there.
JEROME DOCHEZ: What about
the Manifest Merger?
We also have a blame
for the Manifest Merger,
but I don't think we show that.
XAVIER DUCROHET: Yeah,
for the Manifest Merger,
it's harder because
it's per node, right.
JEROME DOCHEZ: So you can have
a text for the Manifest Merger
that tells you which entry
comes from which file.
But I don't think you've
got a visual element of it.
XAVIER DUCROHET: Yeah,
we can do something too.
I'm not sure what the problem
is for Java source file though.
AUDIENCE: So you
want to look at the--
TOR NORBYE: I would basically,
I would javap two folders
and dif the operative javap.
AUDIENCE: OK.
TOR NORBYE: I mean, that would
tell you exactly what happened,
right.
AUDIENCE: Yep.
RETO MEIER: I think
we have just about
time for one last question.
There's no one at the
mic, so I will ask it.
Does Android Studio include
screen reader support?
And if not, when is this coming?
TOR NORBYE: OK, I can take that.
It's something we're working on.
And in fact, we
would like everyone
who needs this to try
it in 2.0 Preview.
So the source editor
itself should now work.
We've tested it
on Windows on Mac.
On Mac, there are some other
JDK bugs that prevent list
from being iterated correctly.
So the best platform right
now for accessibility in 2.0
is Windows with the latest JDK.
But the source editor, actually,
should work everywhere.
RETO MEIER: Right,
so yeah, it would
be great to hear your feedback
if you're impacted by that.
So I think that just
about wraps us up on time.
There's no one
waiting in the queue.
So I'd like to thank all of our
panelists for joining us today.
[APPLAUSE]
And thank you to the audience
for your wonderful questions.
And we'll be around.
Thanks.